The key claim in the analysis of the
scaling algorithm is that the maximum
number of iterations for a scaling phase
is at most twice the number of edges.
By scaling phase, I mean
an iteration of the outer loop here
where we have a fixed value of delta.
We start with the following lemma.
If the residual graph,
with threshold delta, has no s-t paths,
then there exists an s-t cut, A, B,
such that the capacity of the cut
is at most the value of the flow, plus
the number of edges times delta minus 1.
The proof will fill up like
the max flow min cut proof.
We let A be the center of vertices
reachable from s in our residual graph.
And we let B be the complement
of those set of vertices.
Edges from A to B in this graph
must have residual capacity
at most delta minus 1,
otherwise the vertex in
B would be reachable from
the source s and hence a part of A.
And edges from B to A can't have
flow more than delta minus 1,
or their reverse edge would
appear in the residual graph.
The value of the flow then is the flow
out of A minus the flow back into A.
And using these bounds here we can
bound this by the capacity minus
delta minus 1.
And similarly for
these back edges, we can do that
with the delta minus 1 bound.
This then is just the capacity of
the cut, and combining the delta minus 1
terms, well that can only appear
in E number of terms here.
So that gives us the remaining
part of the bound.
With this lemma complete, we now return
to the main claim that we want to prove.
The base case where delta
is equal to C is trivial.
Since each augmenting flow
here saturates one of the edge
out of the source.
For subsequent iterations we let f be
the flow after the scaling phase delta,
and we'll let g be the flow before.
That is, the flow after the previous
scaling, which would be either 2 delta,
or 2 delta + 1, depending on how
the integer division rounding worked.
The value of the flow f is at
most the maximum flow, but
this is at most the capacity of
the s-t cut induced by the flow g,
in the previous iteration, or
the threshold was two delta.
Our lemma then says,
that this is at most, the flow of g,
plus the number of edges, times 2 delta.
Now we let k be
the number of iterations,
that we use to go between the flow g,
and the flow f.
Well then k times delta is a lower bound
on the difference between the value of
the flow f and the value of the flow g.
Each iteration increased
the flow by at least delta.
But from this bound here we have that
this is at most twice the number
of edges times delta.
And so from this then we conclude
that the number of iterations
is at most twice the number of edges.
This then completes the analysis
of the scaling algorithm.
We have at most log C iterations at
the outer loop, order E iterations
of the inner loop, and each one of
these iterations takes order E time.
For a total of E squared log C
as we state in this theorem.
The scaling algorithm returns a maximum
flow in time order e squared log c,
where c is the maximum capacity of
an edge coming out of the source.